you see the left do this routinely
redefining terms
and it's really perverse well now their
new move is to redefine the term court
packing
so for several months now we have been
talking about the fact that during the
democratic primaries
many of the candidates talked about
packing the court even before rbg died
then rbg died and it became a rote
talking point for many democrats
that they would look at packing the
court if they gained control of the
senate now this isn't really as much of
a threat to biden as it is to various
senate candidates
the truth is biden's refusal to denounce
court packing is not going to hurt biden
very much
because the vote for biden is really not
about biden it's really about trump
but it could hurt the democrats down
ballot it could hurt the democrats
in the senate because those races are
very very closely fought
there's the significant possibility
right now and i i think i'd probably put
my money on this
that the that joe biden is leading in
the presidential race
but in the senate republicans hold the
senate because the democrats have gotten
so radical on this issue so instead
they've decided to completely redefine
the term court packing and the media are
going along
with this completely uh donald trump
over the weekend he correctly pointed
out that the radical left democrats are
pushing joe biden to pack the supreme
court so president trump tweeted fdr's
own party told him you cannot pack the
united states supreme court it would
permanently destroy the court
but now the radical left democrats are
pushing biden to do this he has zero
chance
against them and biden so far has not
really stood up to the radical left this
is why and this does undercut biden's
chief message it may it may not matter
but it does undercut a chief message
remember joe biden is i am a solid
moderate
i'm a person who's going to stand up
against the predations of the radical
left i'm a return to normalcy
then why in the world is joe biden so
hesitant to condemn court packing which
is a fundamental change to the nature of
the republic
the minute you have a court that is
openly political people just stop paying
attention to the court
the minute that you have a senate that
has been packed filled with democrats
from new state
and then pushing forward a packed court
and then pushing forward any legislation
to the far left
the american people and various states
are just going to say i'm not paying
attention to that you've now rigged the
system
like truly rigged the system and joe
biden is not standing up to that which
is an amazing thing for a guy who is
campaigning as captain returned to
normalcy
back to moderation back to the future
right then that's a weird take it's a
weird take from
joe biden so over the weekend here was
joe biden trying to redefine the term
court packing so this has been his
consistent message
last week joe biden said that he would
tell you about court packing after the
election he
he just simply refused to answer a
question on whether he would go along
with packing the court he was biden last
week in arizona
they'll know my opinion of court packing
when the election is over now look
i know it's a great question we all and
i don't blame you for asking it
but you know the moment i answer that
question
the headline in every one of your papers
will be about that
other than other than
focusing on what's happening now okay
that was him just last week
okay then over the weekend biden was
asked about all of this okay and this is
clip five
he's specifically asked whether voters
deserve to hear an answer on court
packing and biden's like no they don't
deserve to hear an answer this man has
nothing but scoring for the american
voter and scoring for american
journalists he does not care about
answering the questions joe biden he's a
lifelong politician he's never had to
answer hard questions when he has
answered had to answer hard questions
it's gone poorly for him so
his entire campaign is now going to be i
don't exist
i'm not gonna answer questions because
if i answer questions you might write
about me and i want you to write about
donald trump and he's openly saying this
to the media
and so the media like the good little
lap dogs they are are simply reflecting
it back at him it's incredible it's
incredible
watch here he is openly saying voters do
not deserve an answer on whether he's
going to
wreck the third branch of government sir
i've got to ask you about packing the
courts and i know that sure you said
yesterday you aren't going to answer the
question until after the election
but this is the number one thing that
i've been asked about from viewers
in the past couple of days well you've
been asked by the viewers who are
probably republicans who don't want me
continuing to talk about what they're
doing to the court right now
well sir don't the voters deserve to
know no they don't disagree
i'm not going to play his game he'd love
me to talk about
and i've already said something on on
corporate he loved that to be the
discussion instead of what he's doing
now
okay that is the most absurd answer in
the world no voters don't deserve to
know where i stand on wrecking the third
branch of government
because i want you to talk about donald
trump he's literally just giving
instructions to the media
don't cover this question instead i want
you to cover trump so i'm not going to
give you
an answer okay and then joe biden lays
out the narrative
that has become immediately the rote
narrative for the entire democratic
party and many members of the media and
it's unbelievable
how everything's switched on a dime okay
he decides that he's going to lay out a
narrative whereby the term court packing
itself
no longer means that you pack the court
with extra seats
from people of your political persuasion
instead court packing now means
legally filling the seats that are empty
with people
who are duly nominated and confirmed i'm
not kidding this is his actual case
now the predicate for this case was set
last week by kamal harris so
in debate with mike pence she was
struggling for answers he kept saying
are you packing the court are you gonna
pack the court you're gonna pack the
court and she finally said
you want to talk about court packing
let's talk about court packing and then
she randomly started talking about how
there were no black judges
appointed by donald trump as though they
love clarence thomas over on the left
wing but this is a fundamental
redefinition of the term right
because when people are asking about
court packing they don't mean are you
filling existing empty seats they mean
are you adding seats to courts
to willy-nilly overturn the majorities
that currently exists on those courts
not a seat came open and now you
fill that seat with somebody instead
court packing typically means you add
seats to the core this is not a change
in definition it has been like this for
four generations
during the debate remember i laughed
openly at this when i reviewed the
debate the other night
kamala harris tried to redefine the term
court packing in the middle of the
debate you'll see biden picked it up
then the entire democratic party picked
it up and then the media picked it up
which is normally the way this works
do you know that of the 50 people
who president trump appointed to the
court of appeals for lifetime
appointments not one is black
this is what they've been doing you want
to talk about packing a court let's have
that discussion
okay that is not what packing a court
means packing a court means that you add
seats
to the court that is what has always
meant so now there's this weird
redefinition going on so they don't want
to answer the question
in which we equate filling seats with
people who are constitutionalists and
originalists
duly because the seat is empty and you
get to nominate and confirm judges
we're going to equate that with adding
five
six seven seats on the supreme court
which is crazy
okay so joe biden tried this line also
here was joe biden saying the only court
packing that is happening is happening
with conservatives which of course makes
no sense because conservatives are not
packing the supreme court the only
quarterbacking going on right now is
going on with republicans
in the court now it's not constitutional
what they're doing
we should be focused on what's happening
right now
and the fact is that the only packing
going on is this
court is being packed now by the
republicans
after the vote already begun what the
hell is he talking about filling a seat
that is empty
when you have a majority in the senate
is not court packing that's literally
the constitutional process
it is not adding seeds to the supreme
court okay but this immediately gets
laundered
by the democrats into the media so you
see dick durbin over the weekend
the idiot senator from illinois who once
compared american soldiers to pol pot
here was dick durbin over the weekend
i'd meet the press explaining that if
you fill vacancies this is now packing
the court
now they think you're a i mean
they do they think the american voters
are morons joe biden openly says it
voters don't deserve to know my answer
on court packing
also court packing no longer means court
backing it means duly appointing people
to open positions here's dick durbin
trying to treat the american people as
idiots
american people have watched the
republicans packing the court over the
last three and a half years and they
brag about it
they've taken every vacancy and filled
it did you know that they've sent
us and we have approved only with their
votes i might add
10 people who have been judged
unanimously
unqualified by the american bar
association do you know how many
judicial nominees came from obama who
were judged unanimously unqualified
none so we are dealing with people on
the court packed into the court
with little or no qualification uh who
are going to be there for a long time
so this is incredible so the entire
activist left picks this up the memo
goes out the entire activist left picks
this out
sam berger who is the vice president of
center for american
progress he immediately tweets out
conservative court packing in one chart
and all the chart is is how many judges
were appointed by donald trump
which is 30 right that is the number of
appellate judges confirmed by the united
states senate between 2015 and 2018
is is 30. and then he tweets out
conservatives stealth court packing plan
step one steal seats by blocking
confirmation of judges until white house
and senate are under conservative
control
step two change the rules to appoint the
most partisan conservative judge to
break next speed
so number one i just i'm really enjoying
the redefinition
of a judge who rules according to the
law as a partisan conservative
now if you just do your job as a judge
or a partisan conservative
you are in fact a wondrous human being
if you look into your heart for empathy
the way barack obama described tonya
sotomayor but if you're a judge and you
look at a law and you say you know what
this law doesn't allow this thing
even if i would like it even if it's a
nice thing to do then you're a
conservative
partisan that is the way they've
redefined they've redefined what it
means to be a judge they've redefined
the term judicial activism and now
they're redefining the term court
packing
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content